you
measles mumps rubella hepatitis
pertussis these are a handful of
currently recommended and often required
vaccinations most of us have had the
wonderful experience of getting prodded
by needles at the doctor's office and is
not typically something we look forward
to but besides the minor pain associated
with the shot is there anything to be
afraid of it's undeniable that
vaccination has at the positive effect
of essentially eliminating smallpox and
polio but there are some people
particularly in the United States that
question the safety of the practice so
just how safe are vaccines perhaps the
most notable accusation or at least the
ones supported by the most vocal
minority is that vaccines have the
potential to cause autism this concern
originated from the publication of one
study in the prestigious medical journal
The Lancet in 1997 in this study British
surgeon Andrew Wakefield suggested that
the MMR vaccine was increasing the
likelihood of autism in British children
upon further investigation however the
paper was retracted from The Lancet
after was discovered that Wakefield
committed serious procedural errors
ethical violations and had received
funding from groups opposed to vaccine
manufacturers the study was completely
discredited and Wakefield lost his
medical license over the scandal however
to the medical community's credit they
decided to take Wakefield hypothesis
seriously and conducted further studies
not one of them found any link between
the MMR vaccine and autism despite the
clear falsification of data to achieve a
predetermined result the public was
whipped into a frenzy by the report in
the following years vaccination rates
plummeted by 80% in the UK since then
this one study has been the root cause
of severe damage not only to the public
perception of the MMR vaccine but also
to the medical community as a whole
money and resources that could have been
spent investigating the true causes of
autism were instead diverted to verify
what medical journals later announced to
be an elaborate fraud in the years since
Wakefield study the Center for Disease
Control the National Academy of Sciences
and the UK National Health Service have
all confirmed there is no link between
vaccines and autism prominent hoaxes
aside most safety concerns regarding
vaccines are based upon the claim that
they contain toxic substances such as
formaldehyde mercury and aluminum it's
certainly true that these chemicals are
deadly in sufficient doses but the
amounts contained in fda-approved
vaccines are so miniscule it might
surprise you take formaldehyde for
sample according to the CDC and the FDA
the human metabolic system produces
formaldehyde at a higher rate than is
contained in any vaccine just to be
thorough let's take a look at every
ingredient that gives cautious people
cause for concern first we have SCI
Maricel an organic mercury containing
compound thimerosal has been used as a
preservative in vaccines since the 1930s
today you'll only find it in flu shots
such preservatives are necessary to
prevent fungal or bacterial
contamination part of the original
vaccine autism scandal in 1997 children
were often administered three vaccines
which combined contained a higher level
of mercury than the EPA recommended
those still below the FDA limit the
concern has led to years of research
which show that the type of mercury
presented by Marisol ethyl mercury is
different from methyl mercury the type
we find in fish and know to be dangerous
in large amounts despite the fact that
thimerosal is safe to use its use was
discontinued in 1999 with the exception
of the flu shot for which lamb aerosol
free alternatives are available next up
is formaldehyde formaldehyde is a
tried-and-true ingredient used to
deactivate viruses and detoxify
bacterial toxins present in vaccines
which ensures they don't cause sickness
upon injection the concern here is that
formaldehyde is classified as a
carcinogen and that strong long-term
exposure to the chemical has been known
to cause certain types of cancer as we
heard earlier formaldehyde is present in
the human body in larger amounts than
any vaccine contains according to the
FDA
the average newborn baby has 50 to 70
times more formaldehyde already
circulating in its body than a single
dose of any vaccine could introduce and
that amount increases as we get older
aluminum is also present in vaccines in
trace amounts it's used as what's called
an adjuvant an adjuvant is simply a
substance that strengthens the body's
immune response to vaccination this
means that you need fewer doses of
vaccines to build immunity aluminum
concerns some parents because there is
some evidence to suggest it can
contribute to brain and bone disease and
large doses frankly there is absolutely
no cause for alarm regarding aluminum
why because for starters it's the third
most abundant naturally occurring
element after oxygen and silicon
you'll find trace amounts of aluminum in
plants soil air water even breast milk
on average a baby will ingest 7
milligrams of aluminum through
breastfeeding within the first 6 months
of its life by contrast
all of the standard vaccines that baby
receives during those same six months
contain a total of about four point four
milligrams aluminum has been used safely
in vaccines for over sixty years with no
evidence of any harmful effects next on
our list is antibiotics in some vaccines
antibiotics are used during the
production process to avoid the risk of
bacterial infection the main concern
here is that antibiotics may cause an
allergic reaction in some patients
however there really is no cause for
concern because vaccine manufacturers
select only the antibiotics with the
smallest chance of adverse reaction and
since they're only used in the
production stage these antibiotics are
reduced to negligible or even
undetectable amount in the finished
vaccine not one single allergic reaction
to a vaccine has ever been traced back
to an antibiotic second to last we have
monosodium glutamate or MSG MSG is
simply used as the preservative to
prolong the shelf life of vaccines this
ingredient earned its bad reputation
back in the 1960s after people began
reporting nausea and headaches after
eating food containing MSG however these
effects are without exception short-term
and are not generally supported by
scientific research if you want to avoid
msg make sure you ask at every single
restaurant you visit because it's
considered so safe that it's still
routinely used as a flavor enhancer and
finally the baddest ingredient on the
block
gelatin gelatin is an effective
preservative and stabilizer which allows
vaccines to function properly throughout
their shelf life and under extreme
temperature conditions of all the
ingredients on our list gelatin has the
biggest claim to being dangerous
it's the largest source of allergic
reactions and children however it's not
much of a feat considering the
harmlessness of the other ingredients
and even gelatin only causes a reaction
in one out of every two million patients
that might sound scary until you
consider the fact that your odds of
being struck by lightning are 1 in
10,000 if you still don't like those
odds and somehow manage to make it to
the doctor's office without getting
struck by lightning
there are jealous and free alternatives
available that's the entire list of
ingredients that are often used in anti
vaccination campaigns and as we can see
they're really not so scary ok but even
if that's the case even if vaccines are
harmless shouldn't people be allowed to
choose whether or not to vaccinate their
children short answer no for the longer
answer let's look at some statistics
in every major case of reduction in
vaccinations there has followed a period
of disease resurgence and mortality rate
in Stockholm in 1873 an anti vaccine
motivated by religious objections and
concerns of effectiveness and individual
rights caused a drastic drop in
vaccination rate all the way down to
about 40 percent versus around 90
percent in most of Sweden immediately
following the drop a major smallpox
epidemic ravaged the city this led to a
resurgence in vaccination and
unsurprisingly and end to the epidemic
in the UK during the 1970s a claim was
made that the vaccine for pertussis or
whooping cough was largely ineffective
this proposal came from a well known
public health academic which led to
considerable media coverage and a
subsequent drop in vaccination rates
from 81% to 31% several pertussis
epidemics soon followed and caused the
deaths of a number of unvaccinated
children the mainstream medical opinion
remains strongly in favor of vaccination
and after getting the public back up to
a healthy 90 percent vaccination rate
the epidemics faded even today the
United States is dealing with the
consequences of past anti vaccination
campaigns in 2000 measles was declared
eliminated from the United States
not one single internal case of measles
had been reported in a full year then in
2013 the CDC announced that the three
largest outbreaks of measles that year
had come not from abroad but from groups
of people who refused to vaccinate based
upon religious or philosophical
objections 159 cases were reported in
2013 then the number quadrupled to 644
in 2014 after an influx of unvaccinated
visitors from abroad infected
unvaccinated Americans at Disneyland of
the 288 victims during the first half of
the year 57 percent of them reported to
be unvaccinated by choice on July 2nd of
2015 the first confirmed deaths from
measles in 12 years was recorded you
might be thinking well I vaccinate my
children why should I care there are
several reasons first children have to
be a certain age to receive many
vaccinations and before they reach that
age they are far more susceptible to
infection compounding the problem is the
fact that very young children already
have relatively weak immune systems so
babies born into a society with a large
number of infected people have a
drastically higher chance of getting the
disease themselves which can often lead
to death
infants aren't the only at-risk
demographic the elderly as well as
immunocompromised individuals often lack
the immune response required to fight
such diseases and finally in some rare
cases it is possible for vaccinated
people to contract diseases like the
measles during the Disneyland Fiasco six
people who have received their MMR
vaccines still manage to get infected
this only happens in cases where the
individuals immune response was not
strong enough to build up adequate
antibodies to fight the disease and does
not reflect poorly on the vaccine itself
as the MMR vaccine is regarded to be one
of the most effective around the world
at the heart of the matter is simply
human nature we're conditioned to blow
perceived danger out of proportion and
minimize the risk of routine tasks take
driving a car versus flying in an
airplane driving is statistically far
more dangerous than flying but we do it
every day without hesitation and an
alarming number of people drive while
texting but the minute we step into an
airplane we're certain it's going to
crash the same holds true for vaccines
some people see a list of potential
side-effects and immediately assume
they'll suffer them all while completely
ignoring the fact that contracting the
disease the vaccine prevents would be
much much more dangerous the fact that
anti vaccination and disease outbreaks
are so clearly linked should be enough
evidence for people to protect
themselves and their loved ones but
unfortunately that doesn't seem to be
the case when it comes down to it the
scientific consensus is as close to
unanimous as you can possibly get and
it's apparent that vaccines do not cause
autism posed no major health risks and
offer a type of security from disease
that nothing else can let's hope that
humanity can learn from past mistakes
and effectively work together to get
everyone vaccinated and eradicate these
preventable diseases once and for all as
this can be a sensitive subject for a
lot of people I've provided a
comprehensive list of links sources and
further reading in the description feel
free to look them over for more
information regarding the history of
vaccinations and disease prevention if
you enjoyed this video remember to
subscribe to keep up to date with the
latest content and leave a comment down
below with your thoughts on the subject
you can watch my previous video by
clicking here
or watch them all by clicking here don't
forget to follow second thought on your
favorite social media thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video
you